[Music]
mike tannenbaum works for the mothership
espn front office insider former nfl
executive and he founded the 33rd team a
football think tank consisting of former
nfl head coaches gm's and grad
students creating in-depth analysis on
college in pro football
and that's the 33rd team provides
insights with a lot of depth and
experience and perspectives here and
mike is kind enough to join us mike can
a gm talk to odell beckham can you ask
for that right now
absolutely so after four o'clock dan
yesterday he was a free agent and a 401
i'm on the phone with him if i'm the gm
of any team that's contending what about
coach quarterback does that happen
absolutely and we're going to tell him
hey look here's the exact role we want
you to play here's a scheme and you come
in and let's just flush what's happened
in the past cleveland giants that's
ancient history come in give us eight
meaningful regular season games we'll go
the postseason and we want to set you up
obj to make a lot of money next march
hopefully it's with us if not it'll be
with another team
yeah if you had two questions mike as a
gm what would you ask odell beckham
number one
is it in the past
the reputation was you rather lose 49 47
and have 150 catches than win 10-6 with
only one catch
is that fair or unfair
and then number two would be is you know
what are your goals what do you want to
accomplish how do you expect to get
there
see i would want to know what what role
did he play in the video that was put
out by his dad
now that that you know he kind of
submarined baker mayfield or at least
co-signed on this would that concern you
as a gm signing odell beckham
yeah absolutely i want to know that
you're in charge of you and everybody
else around you and
the depends on your hand obj in terms of
what you want everyone to think of you
because right now there is noise there's
a lot of distractions so
you could flush it that could be ancient
history or if that comes here
and it doesn't work here after you're 13
usually you're you're a minimum guy so
depends on your hand what do you want
people to think of you
the team that makes the most sense for
odell beckham jr is who
you know dan to me it's green bay and
here's why you come in
you're with aaron rodgers you're on the
opposite of devante arms you're in an
ideal situation
and aaron rodgers
all that noise aside of what's just
happened dan he's running the program
there and he'll tell you exactly where
you want to be the routes at what depth
if you do this you're going to get the
ball if you don't
we'll go and get the ball to alizard and
valdis scanley and everybody else so you
need somebody who's strong conviction
it's a lot like tom brady antonio brown
it's really a win-win and having aaron
there will give obj the best chance to
be successful
what about tampa what about kansas city
what about seattle you got strong
quarterbacks
yeah i think tampa there's just too much
there between you know antonio brown
godwin evans brock i i just don't know
if there's enough opportunity kansas
city you know they just try to run that
same play dan with josh gordon so i you
know maybe three weeks ago seattle to me
is a possibility um and then the other
team you know he's from louisiana and
let's face it the saints have a really
good defense michael thomas is out for
the year but the quarterback situation
right now is a big question mark so if i
was representing obj the saints would be
at the bottom of that group because i
just don't know how productive i would
be yeah i and you can't put him in a
situation where he's going to respect
trevor simeon and trevor simeon even
though that's his number one receiver
you still have to placate him and i
think that's where baker mayfield got in
trouble early is this is obj
i want him to be my friend i want him to
respect me and defenses have to know
this mike that he is going to zero in on
him are the browns better without odell
beckham and if so why
yeah dan it's really remarkable the
stats backing up the take back stuff
because i think baker just plays
quarterback you know last week jarvis
landry had 11 yards receiving he he was
a non-factor but eight different players
touched the ball chubb obviously had a
big game denzel wore out a pick six they
put up a lot of points because they were
diverse on their offense and donovan
people's jones was a big time recruit
coming out of the michigan area
and when he played michigan there was
really just very poor quarterback play i
think he has a chance to be really good
i'm not saying like an elite star but he
could be a bonafide really solid
receiver so they have a number of
weapons and they could just play offense
and not worry about obj he's mike
tannenbaum espn front office insider
former nfl executive if you were the gm
of the browns
what would you do with baker mayfield
long term
i have massive concerns he's height and
speed deficient and dan if you and i
were running a team he's maybe maybe the
sixth best quarterback in the afc when
you think about josh allen and patrick
mahomes and justin herbert derek carr
like this is the golden age
of quarterbacks in the afc arguably he's
the third best quarterback in the afc
north behind lamar and joe burrow so i'm
paying him maybe in that mid-tier market
but we can't win a championship with
baker mayfield do we want to go to war
every day with the sixth or seventh best
quarterback in our conference
but there is no mid-tier though mike
this is what i keep arguing that it
feels like next guy up is going to make
40 to 45 million or you cut him
i would love to have that
if i'm an agent that there's a there's a
landing spot here that i'm my guy's
gonna make 28 million dollars a year
let's let's just throw out a random
number here that that feels like it's
amenable for both both sides but it
doesn't happen why
well because there's massive egos on
both sides and and you're right the
number to be is 28 to 30 with kirk
cousins somewhere in that range
baker mayfield to me here's the
conversation hey you stay here you're
going to hit 100 of a double which by
the way is probably 130 to 180 million
dollars over the next six to seven years
and we could go keep wyatt tell her who
we just signed where to keep denzel ward
nick chubb we have a really good team
and you're a meaningful part or you can
go leave and go sign with some bad team
and go make whatever the number is 38
million 39 million you know maybe you
get lucky and go to carolina that has a
great defense but chances are you may go
to a team that's rebuilding so if you
want to make the most money it's not
going to be here in cleveland but if you
want to have a chance to win with a lot
of good teammates you're going to have
to take
as you said somewhere between 28 and 30
million dollars
why is cam newton still out of football
dan that's a great question every week
on espn i would sign cam newton to a
two-year deal from pittsburgh if i'm new
orleans and here's why
ben roethlisberger had a great career
through the hall of fame he's not good
enough anymore and he's
declining this year and he's worse next
year
if you're the saints you don't have a
quarterback under contract for next year
so the draft doesn't look great maybe
pick it out of pit could be a first
rounder but if you get cam newton to
sign for this year or next year you're
solidifying that position while you look
for somebody else and while he's not
perfect he's another year off for
shoulder surgery and i think it's a
no-brainer assignment to a two-year deal
what did you think of the dolphins
flirting with deshawn watson
they were doing their job i mean if you
go back to uh his freshman year at
alabama when you come into these
programs in the nfl or big time college
football you're competing he beat out
jalen hurts her
transfer to oklahoma and we always tell
players dan like you're competing
against the backups in this in this
building and anybody else we can get so
it's competition they were doing their
job and by the way here's the other
thing that was smart about what miami
did dan
if they're interested in him in march
they now have a massive head start over
carolina denver and all these other
teams so
if tua can't handle and be mentally
tough to know that there's going to be
competition they have the wrong guy so i
think what they did was smart and
proactive
let me uh circle back to aaron rodgers
before i let you go is he more likely to
stay or less likely to stay with what
just happened
i think it's a massive opportunity for
the green bay packers i'm running into
aaron rodgers house i'm brian gooda i'm
knocking on the door and say hey we got
your back we're gonna handle the fines
all the noise go be a great teammate go
win a championship and i'll tell you
this stan ironically i traded for far
back with the jets you could hear in
their voice that they knew they had
something special with aaron rodgers
they don't have that with jordan love
this is an opportunity to start
recruiting aaron that hey you're you're
a big part of what we're going to do
you'll have a say on the roster you're
not going to be the gm but if you
suggest a guy like randall cobb we're
going to take that you know into
consideration but we have your back and
to me if i'm green bay dan this is an
opportunity at a time that he's getting
criticized to show
him how much we care about you
how did you initiate trade talks with
green bay for farv
called every day you know to me the word
no is a great conversation starter it
took us about three weeks to convince
brett that like coming to the jets was
not practicing in freaking times square
as ironically it was john gruden who's
the head coach of tampa
and we just wore him down and we just
put together a compelling case we
actually i told him that i was going to
find him every tuesday that he didn't
hunt for fish and that there was a big
farm about 10 miles from our facility
and
we just we showed that he could have a
great experience both on and off the
field and but for a shoulder injury dan
i'm sure he would be taking a level 42
cbd now if he could have back then he
would have uh
he would have uh maybe got us over the
hump but brett was a great experience
who were you competing against to get
farv
it was tampa and what the problem for us
was you know he was in mississippi he
played for john gruden in
up in green bay and he didn't know brian
schottenheimer our coordinator eric
bangini or myself so we actually sent
google at google satellite imaging of
this farm and said hey brett every
tuesday you are not allowed in the
building you have to hunt and fish
you're going to be in the building three
days a week we got a great bunch of
dudes you're gonna be really happy here
and let's go beat new england and you
know we finally you know after about
three weeks of getting the word no we
finally got him over the hump
but you also are fighting this image of
you go to new york and oh my god i got
to deal with all of this
you don't have to deal with any of that
you guys are you know out in the suburbs
in new jersey
right but dan you know that and i know
that like you're a northeast guy you're
in connecticut if you're brett favre and
you're on a 500 acre farm and i saw it
when we went to get him it's every inch
of 500 acres
new york is a very intimidating place
and i
i will go to my grave convinced that
once he got those google satellite
images of this farm and it's a 12
million 12 minute drive from florin park
to this farm that he was going to have a
great experience and i think that was a
game changer because all he kept hearing
from tampa is if you go to the jets
you're gonna be in times square there's
traffic you're gonna hate it there so
this is a guy that was from the south
went to school in the south played in
green bay and we had to convince him
that there was actually you know we have
trees in new jersey
mike great to catch up with you as
always thanks great stuff
yeah appreciate you having me thanks dan
it's mike tannenbaum espn front office
insider former nfl executive and uh
founder of the 33rd team